uh yeah he might be playing again d3s  what he played yesterday against  rockford yeah  i think but he's not going to get 97  on that move that's a given that's for  sure and here we see kariakin has  arrived and the ceremonial first move is  d4 it's d4 okay will magnus take that  move let's see if it stays  i remember an interview years ago at the  london chess classic where magnus  his first move was made by a young child  and he just felt uh  i think felt too awkward to take the  move back so he just made he just let it  happen even though it wasn't his  intention on move one but so what do you  think it stays well let's stay he hasn't  moved it back yet  okay  that would be strange if he if he takes  it back also  okay and he does  he kept it there look at that he kept it  there for a minute he's teasing sergey  but  and play the  eventually  so we're expecting  some variant of